larry fitzgerald of the arizona
cardinals here how are you Larry I'm
doing off that anytime I get a chance to
come home and view them I'm in a good
place
I appreciate that right back at you
where work what place are you in
mentally physically entering season 15
for you Larry I feel wonderful words are
healthy enthusiastic excited about the
prospects of our team and you know what
we've what we've worked so hard this
offseason and preseason to accomplish
their regular season so I'm really happy
with the position land in the guy and we
have I'm excited yeah
coach Steve Wilk says that the identity
for the team is set what would you say
the identity of this team is Larry I
mean you look at the preseason we're
going to be a team that's gonna you know
be opportunistic offensively without
make plays costs turnovers sort of run
the ball efficient they take our shots
but you know be efficient don't put
ourselves in that position win on
special teams and um you know it's the
kind of that's kind of the team that
we're being built you know it's a to be
and you know I'm really happy about that
we're gonna play a really downhill game
stop the run and you know I think that
we've all had success with this so when
it all comes down to it you're you're so
you know decade and a half it's your NFL
career Larry and he would kind of have
to learn from an with a new quarterback
in a way right I mean what's your
relationship with Sam Bradford on field
all field like Larry Oh a great
relationship with Sam on and off the
field
he's uh he's really easy to work with
really Chilkat and you know as I've
never really had any problems you know I
just wanted new guys I'm gonna play with
a plethora different quarterbacks over
my career and you know the one thing is
you can get open and you catch the ball
when I go to you they usually like you
so I'm gonna I'm gonna try to continue
to do that what does Josh Rosen look
like to you though knowing quarterbacks
as well as you do and what he could look
like eventually if not already he's he's
a stud I love how cerebro he is and and
how much he wants it like in terms of
information he loves learning and asking
questions and wants to know about this
covers in this player and you know
he just he's very inquisitive you know
he's got a real thirst for knowledge
I mean he's intrinsically motivated to
be great you see him doing extra work
every day at the practice would buy a
leverage and just he just he just gets
it he just gets it he's very young but
he understands what it comes what's
gonna take them to be a great great
player in terms of his work ethic Mary
Fitzgerald here on the Rich Eisen show
let's be honest with each other we
always are I mean your team's overlooked
in the NFC West nobody's talking right
now we're talking about the Rams and how
loaded they look have coming off of last
year and Jimmy G up in San Francisco
where Richard Sherman now resides even
Seattle gets a lot of buzz based on
Russell Wilson and Pete Carroll etc do
you feel you're being overlooked in
Arizona right now deservedly are getting
the attention obviously the Rams made
playoffs last year Seattle been a
perennial powerhouse for a very long
time and the way San Francisco finished
the season with Jimmy playing so well I
mean those things should be talked about
and you know we're fine with where we
are you know we're not out to be
household names or anything like that we
we know who we are and we're comfortable
who we are and you know when you start
worrying about what everybody else is
the thing in the our view you know you
lost focus and lost track of what's
really important Larry Fitzgerald here
on the Rich Eisen show all right let's
get into your relationship with John
McCain I was so moved with what you said
and then the whole entire week the
weekend the memorial service in
Washington DC on Saturday what was the
first time you met him how did you meet
Senator McCain McCain in passing about
12 years ago and I just gotten out here
and you know I not had heard of him I I
knew what he I knew he was a senator and
I knew about his story but I hadn't
really got a chance to know but for some
reason he just really took a liking to
me risk I mean he stayed in contact with
me and you know we started having more
dialog and I got a chance to down and
break bread with him one time and he
started telling me stories about you
know it is trials and tribulations over
in Vietnam and I was kind of moved I
wanted to go see and experience
everything that he went through and
started the trip over there dedicated
primarily to see the
and then I bounced around from there but
you know I really wanted to learn you
know more about him and our relationship
just continue to grow from that point on
well what did you learn from him in
general um the thing I really really
admired about him is obviously he was a
Republican and he was he was a senator
and but you know that didn't that didn't
define who he was as a man and you know
obviously people might not agree with
some of his political views but my
relationship was not a political
relationship my relationship was based
on the merit of his of his heart and the
character that he does quickly when I
was in his presence and and I really
just respected who he was as a man and
what he stood for with his family and
obviously you do not take the hat to
what he did in terms of his sacrifice
for his country he endured things that
none of us who ever have to and you know
I just really admire him for that so did
you ever talk life issues politics did
you ever talk politics with him I don't
any point Larry no no he would he told
me up he told me a couple of times it he
think I would think I thought I would be
good in politics my son there's no way I
would ever do anything like that you
know it's impossible everything done
nowadays you know everybody's got their
own agendas nobody wants to work
together so I was like no that's not
that's not my future I want to be
sitting next to rich one day uh-huh you
want to be sitting next on the paparazzi
he worked did he really thought that do
you really thought you you you should
run for office he told you that at some
point you know it was it was it was more
tongue-in-cheek you know just messing
around with me you know he we had the
type of relationship you know the
friendly banter and things like that he
he had a wonderful sense of humor and
not really enjoyed how witty he was and
you know this is the his text messages
if I didn't have a solid game okay what
are you doing though you getting you get
a little old man you look at looking
like me out there right now you know you
know saying stuff like that to me and
you know he had a really wonderful
something humor hmm and how were you
asked that he personally asked you to be
part of his funeral to your Allah John's
because I know he personally asked you
yeah yep um it was him and his wife
Cindy and Meghan who were there and they
they asked me to do it so it was it was
it was a great cause a tremendous honor
were you surprised to be asked I mean uh
well how did it feel to be asked one of
the all-time greats of his generation if
not all time politically in this country
to you I mean it was basically you Joe
Biden President Obama and President W
Bush we spoke on yeah I was I was really
I was really taken back you know really
taken back and you know I talked to my
dad and talked to a couple other people
and I I mean I really didn't know harder
to take it you know initially but you
know as I as I kind of thought about the
magnitude and and and what he meant to
me and what he meant to this country I
need I needed to be you know be ready
and and to do my best to honor a man
that you know that the world truly will
miss and you know I worked this is an
April so I mean he told me this in April
and and obviously you know we're in
September now so I had some time to kind
of prepare my thoughts and my notes and
you know talk about some of the things
that you know I think you know
solidified our relationship a few more
minutes here left with Larry Fitzgerald
Iran the Rich Eisen show I've been told
that there is an announcement today in
regards to the stadium that you have
christened in so many different ways
yourself Larry what's going on with the
stadium today well today you know we've
announced a new stadium rights deal with
State Farm and you know obviously
farmers it is a largely recognizable
company I mean a fortune 40 company you
know millions of millions of clients
including myself and so we're honored to
have our new partner State Farm we had a
wonderful partner and University of
Phoenix for many years and you know what
we're excited about were started about
the future
okay speaking of which how many years do
you think you'll be playing in State
Farm Stadium Larry what do you think
well Richard you told me I was done
about three or four years on your
podcast and I heard that risk I was I
was really hurt by that I want you know
that I was I was really hurt but you
know I wanted to prove wrong and you
know I'm still hanging on right now
okay hang on well then speaking on
behalf of all Cardinals fans and people
who love watching you play you're done
you're done you're finished stop trying
Larry stop trying all right I'm at the
food I might keep proving you wrong then
monica's you sound you even started
saying that you feel good you feel you
know excited it's your 15 so and you're
starting again I know Sam Bradford is is
an old hand at this but he's still new
to you and you got a young rookie behind
and a coach who's never been at this
level before many veterans in this
situation might look around a locker
room so what am I still doing here
you know no that's one of the main
reasons I wanted to come back you know
because you know I was there I was
comfortable with co-chairing I knew what
to expect I knew what my role was now a
minute I'm in a position where I had I
literally had to come out and earn it
you know cause Brooks in the first day
he met with us he said that every
position on this 53-man roster will have
to be earned and I literally felt like I
earned my position I made plays in
training camp in OTAs I was there
participating every day in OTAs a mini
camp once I haven't done in years you
know I come and go you know you know
based on how I was feeling but I was
there every day this year and and this
the excitement of having you know your
roster turnover for 50% brand new
coaching staff new offensive play called
all these things and you know really
kind of got me excited and more so just
kind of reinvigorated me and I'm you
know so I feel like I'm a I feel like
I'm a rookie right now but also I
haven't been hit since last January
either so he talked to me on Monday much
I might be saying again
you called me from the cold tub is that
your same after you have to take on
Washington we call me from the cold tub
because amazing Larry I mean you know it
the guys who were in the wide reciever
room with you when you were first
drafted and became friends with John
McCain some of these guys were in grade
school third fourth grade I'm not lying
that's not an exaggeration it's crazy
I don't I got a picture of Christian
Kirk it was my second year in 2005 I was
doing a football camp I'm here locally
and I took a picture with him and he was
like literally in third grade and I was
like oh my what's the point of showing
me this which is it show me how old I am
is that that was you show me this
picture for you I had to give him a hard
time for the head calling you grandpa
and all that stuff I know I know
at least at least I have a few more
strands of hair than you do what seed
was he in our in our football hair
contest that we did the the bracket I
think Larry was like was he was he at NC
busy a nine seed I forget which just
don't go Jerry Rice honest Larry you
don't to be hanging onto the stage for
too long down in the record books I mean
there's not many people that's right
there in front of you it really is
amazing what you've got potential
milestones this year 92 catches you
passed you passed tony gonzalez 309 to
receiving yards you're only behind Jerry
passing tio 48 receptions
you would pass Jerry Rice for the most
receptions with one team in NFL history
I mean what would that mean to you Larry
oh you know Jerry Rice has something I
truly covered he's got three Super Bowl
rings and at this point you're 15 I
don't personal activate the numbers I
mean that's that's for the for the
pundits and to discuss and talk about
you know I'm in it to win it and that's
the one goal I'm chasing is uh those
Super Bowl rings and that's the reason
that we all come back and play all right
Larry let's get chatting with you you
saw I can't get out of it I mean is this
it I'll just flat-out ask you is is
there is it possible there's more years
left after this one
Larry oh stop in the National Football
League you suit up helmet on pads on
getting out there and playing is it
possible it's a possibility yes I say
it's a possibility but I don't know how
likely it is right now like yeah like I
told you
I'm fresh I feel the best I've felt in a
long time but I have not been tackled
yet so we'll see we will see Larry great
job again eulogizing Senator McCain it
was so moving and it was so well done
that could that could not have been easy
at all for you to do that for a friend
to be on a stage like that
kudos to you I just wanted to call you
and tell you that among other things
just to connect with you oh thank you
very much I appreciate you having me on
it's always a pleasure
right back at you Larry you have a great
season we'll chat down the line thank
you I look Portola you bet that's Larry
Fitzgerald here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience